Je veux simplement dire, au cours des dernières années, j'ai été -
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire cette conférence de clôture.
Et on m'a présenté de plusieurs façons fantastiques.
Il y a environ 8 ans,
Billy Graham m'a lancé
et je pensais qu'il y avait -
(Rires)
Je pensais qu'il n'y avait absolument aucun moyen imaginable
de faire mieux.
Mais je voulais simplement dire -
et je le dis sans ironie -
je pense que je peux parler au nom de tout le public
quand je dis que plût à Dieu que vous soyez le président des États-Unis.
(Applaudissements)
Bon, voilà le titre de mon allocution d'aujourd'hui.
(Rires)
Je veux seulement vous donner un rapide aperçu .
Tout d'abord, veuillez vous souvenir que je suis entièrement politiquement correct,
et tout ce que je dis, c'est avec beaucoup d'affection.
Si certains parmi vous ont l'estomac sensible ou se sentent nauséeux,
c'est le moment de vérifier votre Blackberry.
(Rires)
Juste pour avis, ceci est mon TEDTalk.
Nous allons faire quelques plaisanteries,
quelques gags,
quelques petits sketches -
et puis nous allons parler du point de Lagrange L1.
(Rires)
Ainsi, les - l'une des questions que je me pose
est, était-ce le TED le plus pénible que nous ayons eu ?
Essayons de résumer les choses, voulez-nous?
Des images de la régénération d'un membre
et de visages criblés de variole :
21 pour cent de la conférence.
(Rires)
Mentions de la noyade des ours polaires : quatre pour cent.
Des images de la Terre annihilée par les inondations ou la grippe aviaire : 64 pour cent.
(Rires)
Et David Pogue qui chante des génériques d'émissions.
(Applaudissements)
Parce que c'est le TED le plus pénible qu'on ai jamais eu,
j'ai travaillé avec Neil Gershenfeld sur le sac TED de l'année prochaine.
Et si le - si la conférence est à moitié aussi pénible -
alors - nous aurons un sac à hurlements l'année prochaine.
(Rires)
Ça va être un sac à hurlements du berceau au berceau , bien sûr.
Alors vous allez pouvoir faire ça.
(Rires)
Apportez-le ici
et ouvrez-le. Aaaah!
(Rires)
Pendant ce temps, à l'Université TED,
cette femme merveilleuse vous enseigne comment émincer des chips.
(Rires)
Ainsi, Robert Wright - Je ne sais pas,
j'ai eu l'impression que si il y avait quelqu'un à qui Helen devait donner des antidépresseurs,
ce pourrait être lui.
Je tiens à interférer de façon délibérée avec son taux de dopamine.
(Rires)
Il parlait de la morale.
La morale de la classe économique c'est :
" Nous voulons vous réduire à l'âge de pierre à coup de bombes."
La morale de classe affaires c'est :
"Ne bombardez pas le Japon - ils ont construit ma voiture."
Et la morale de première classe c'est : "Ne bombardez pas le Mexique - ils nettoient ma maison."
(Rires)
Oui, c'est politiquement incorrect.
- Très bien.
maintenant je veux faire un peu d'un truc pour vous ...
(Rires)
Bon, maintenant ce sont les que -
Je dirais que, bla, bla-
bla, bla, bla, bla,
bla-aaaah!
(Rires)
Donc, je voulais vous montrer -
je voulais parler d'une nouvelle interface informatique révolutionnaire
qui vous permet de travailler avec des images tout aussi facilement -
que vous - qu'une interface utilisateur entièrement naturelle.
(Rires)
Et vous pouvez -
vous pouvez utiliser des gestes de la main vraiment naturels
pour faire, genre, comme ça.
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant, nous avons eu un professeur de Harvard ici -
elle était de Harvard, je voulais juste le dire et -
et elle était effectivement professeur à Harvard.
Et elle parlait d'univers inversés à sept dimensions.
Avec, vous savez, bien sûr, il y a le cerveau gravitationnel,
il y a le cerveau faible, et puis il y a mon cerveau faible,
qui est trop - trop - absolument trop faible pour comprendre
de quel putain de truc elle peut bien parler.
(Rires)
Maintenant !
l'une des choses qui est très importante pour moi
est d'essayer de comprendre ce que je fais sur Terre.
Et c'est pourquoi je suis allé faire des courses
et j'ai choisi un best-seller sur la réussite en affaires.
Vous savez, il se fonde essentiellement sur la mythologie grecque.
Et c'est un gars nommé pasteur Rick Warren qui l'a écrit,
et il est intitulé
"La vie guidée par un marsouin".
(Rires)
Et Rick est comme
un dieu païen,
que qui m'a semblé approprié,
d'une certaine manière.
Et maintenant, nous allons voir
quelques visuels sur Rick Warren.
OK
(Rires)
Bien.
Maintenant, le rouge est Rick Warren,
et le vert, Daniel Dennett, OK ?
(Rires)
L'échelle représente ici la religiosité à partir de zéro pour cent, ou athée
à 100 pour cent, l'interprétation littérale de la Bible.
Et puis là ce sont les livres vendus - à l'échelle logarithmique.
(Rires)
30 mille, 300 mille, 3 millions, 30 millions, 300 millions.
OK, maintenant, ils s'affrontent. Maintenant, ils s'affrontent.
(Rires)
Et Rick Warren prend l'avantage, il prend l'avantage.
Ouaip, et emprise devient un peu plus grande.
(Rires)
Mais les idées dangereuses de Darwin remontent. Elles remontent.
Je vais souligner le tracé, pour que vous puissiez mieux voir .
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant, l'une des choses qui est très importante,
Nicholas Negroponte nous a parlé d'un portique par -
désolé --
(Rires)
d'un portable par enfant.
Maintenant, nous allons parler de certaines des caractéristiques
qui sont importantes pour cet appareil révolutionnaire.
Je vais vous parler un peu des paramètres de conception,
et puis je vais vous le montrer pour de vrai.
Tout d'abord, il doit être petit.
Il doit être plat, pour être transportable.
Léger. Portable.
Utiliser très, très peu d'énergie.
Très, très haute résolution.
Doit être visible en plein jour. Fonctionner n'importe où.
Et largement utilisable sur de nombreux systèmes d'exploitation.
Maintenant, nous avons été jusqu'à faire des recherches -
Neil Gershenfeld et les Fab Labs ont fait des études de marché.
Ils ont fait quelques recherches, nous sommes rentrés, et nous pensons que nous avons le prototype parfait
de ce que les étudiants dans le domaine demandent vraiment.
Et voici,
l'ordinateur à 100 dollars.
(Rires)
OK, OK, OK, OK - parfait, parfait.
Maintenant, j'ai acheté cet appareil à Clifford Stoll pour environ 900 dollars.
Et lui et son équipe de collégiens
ont fait de la vraie science.
Nous essayons donc de vérifier et de faire un balayage ici,
pour voir qui consomme de la marijuana.
(Rires)
Pour voir qui consomme de la marijuana.
Allons-nous être en mesure de trouver de la marijuana, Jim Young ?
Seulement en ouvrant assez de casiers de vestiaires.
(Rires)
OK, maintenant la variole est une maladie extrêmement pénible.
Le Dr Larry Brilliant nous a raconté comment nous avons éradiqué la variole.
Je voulais vous montrer les étapes de la variole.
Nous commençons. C'est le premier jour.
(Rires)
Le deuxième jour.
Le troisième jour, elle a une grosse vérole massive sur son épaule.
Le troisième jour.
Quatrième jour
(Rires)
Cinquième jour
et sixième jour.
(Rires)
Maintenant la bonne nouvelle, c'est que parce que je suis un professionnel de la médecine qualifié,
je sais que, même si elle sera marquée pour la vie,
elle va se rétablir complètement.
(Rires)
Maintenant la bonne nouvelle à propos des Architectes pour l'Humanité
est qu'ils sont vraiment le plus étonnant des groupes.
Ils ont parrainé un concours de design
pour trouver des solutions novatrices en matière de logement médicaux,
de solutions pour faire des cliniques, en Afrique,
et ils ont fait un concours de design.
Maintenant, ce qui est merveilleux, c'est que Larry Brilliant venait d'être
nommé à la tête de la Fondation Google.
Alors il a décidé qu'il soutiendrait --
il apporterait son soutien au travail de Cameron.
Et la façon dont il a décidé de soutenir ce travail
a été d'expédier 50 000 conteneurs
de collations Google.
(Rires)
Je tiens donc à vous montrer quelques prototypes.
Les Nations Unies - vous savez, il leur a fallu 20 ans rien que pour ajouter un auvent à une tente.
Mais je pense que nous avons des choses plus excitantes.
C'est une maison entièrement faite en bonbons au fruits
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et ces cookies roulés avec - enrobés de chocolat blanc.
Et ce qui est vraiment merveilleux avec ça,
c'est que quand vous avez terminé --
vous pouvez la manger.
Mais ce qui me passionne vraiment, vraiment beaucoup,
c'est cette incroyable maison en Müesli.
(Rires)
Et la maison en Müesli a un toit spécial en chips Sun
pour recueillir l'eau et la recycler.
Et c'est - sur ce côté, il y a des bonbons acidulés classiques
et des oursons de gélatine pour laisser entrer la lumière.
(Rires)
Mais de ce côté, il y a des oursons au sucre
pour diffuser la lumière plus légèrement.
Et nous - nous voulions juste vous montrer à quoi cela pourrait ressembler in situ.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Alors, Einstein -
Einstein, dis-moi -
Quelle est ta chanson préférée?
Non, j'ai dit quelle est ta chanson préférée?
"Free Bird". (oiseau libre)
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
OK, alors, Einstein,
Quel est ton groupe préféré ?
Peux-tu répéter ? Quel est ton groupe préféré ?
OK, une fois de plus - je vais juste t'aider un peu.
Ton groupe préféré - c'est Diana Ross et les -
Public: Supremes !
Tom Reilly: Exactement.
(Applaudissements)
Pourrions-nous avoir le son sur l'ordinateur portable, s'il vous plaît?
(Rires)
"Free Bird" me rappelle que si vous -
Si vous écoutez "Free Bird" à l'envers,
voici ce que vous pourriez entendre.
Ordinateur : Satan. Satan. Satan. Satan.
Satan. Satan. Satan.
TR : Maintenant, c'est un peu difficile d'entendre tout le message, alors je voulais -
(Rires)
alors je voulais vous aider un peu.
Ordinateur : Mon doux Satan. Dan Dennett adore Satan.
Achète "La vie guidée par des marsouins", ou Satan prendra ton âme.
(Rires)
TR : Donc,
nous avons beaucoup parlé de réchauffement de la planète,
mais, vous savez, comme Jill a dit, ça semble plutôt agréable -
beau temps en hiver, et à New York.
Et comme Jay Walker l'a souligné, ce n'est tout simplement pas assez effrayant.
Ainsi, Al, je pense effectivement que je suis plutôt doué pour créer des images de marque.
J'ai donc essayé de trouver un bon programme de conception
pour inventer un nouveau terme qui remplacerait "réchauffement de la planète."
Nous avons donc commencé avec Babel Fish. Nous y avons mis réchauffement de la planète.
Et puis nous avons décidé que nous allions le traduire de l'anglais vers le néerlandais -
"Het Globale Verwarmen."
Du néerlandais au chinois, "Hordahordaneecheewa."
(Rires)
du chinois au portugais : Aquecer-se global.
Puis du portugaise au latin de cuisine.
(Rires)
Aquecer-se ucked-fay.
Et puis enfin de nouveau en anglais,
ce qui donne, "nous sommes complètement foutus".
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant, je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais Michael Shermer a parlé de la tendance des êtres humains à -
du point de vue de l'évolution, ils sont conçus pour voir des formes dans les choses.
Par exemple, dans des sandwichs au fromage.
Pouvez-vous regarder attentivement et voir si vous apercevez la Vierge Marie ?
J'ai essayé de le rendre un peu plus visible.
(Rires)
Est-ce la Vierge Marie ?
Ou bien est-ce Mena Trott ?
Bon, j'ai parlé à Josh Prince-Ramus du centre des congrès
et des conférences. Il devient terriblement grand.
Il devient juste un peu trop grand. C'est plein à craquer, un peu, ici .
Nous avons donc essayé de trouver un programme -
pour remodeler ce bâtiment afin de mieux recevoir TED.
Tout d'abord, nous avons décidé -
(Rires)
que nous avions besoin d'environ un tiers de librairie,
un tiers de cyber-café Google,
environ 20 pour cent d'accueil, 80 pour cent d'hôtel de luxe,
environ cinq pour cent pour les toilettes.
Et puis, bien sûr, nous voulions avoir le salon de diffusion simultanée,
le hall et le forum Steinbeck.
Maintenant, laissez-moi vous montrer
comment cela se traduit littéralement dans le programme de conception.
Tout d'abord,
l'un des problèmes avec Monterey, c'est que si il y a le réchauffement climatique
et que le Groenland fond comme vous le dites, le niveau des océans
va augmenter de 6 mètres et inonder le centre des congrès.
Donc, nous allons construire ce nouveau bâtiment sur pilotis.
Nous construisons donc ce bâtiment sur pilotis,
puis ici -
(Rires)
C'est là que nous allons mettre le nouvel auditorium Steinbeck.
Et ce qui est merveilleux avec la nouvelle librairie c'est,
qu'elle sera en forme de spirale organisée selon le Système de Classification Décimale de Dewey.
(Rires)
Ensuite, nous allons faire un escalator qui vous aidera à monter là-haut.
Et enfin, nous allons mettre l'Hôtel Marriott
et le Plaza Portola au sommet.
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant, je ne sais pas pour vous, mais parfois j'ai ces images dans ma tête
de séparation à la naissance.
Je ne sais pas pour vous, mais quand je vois Aubrey de Grey,
je pense tout de suite à Gandalf le Gris.
(Rires)
OK. Maintenant, nous avons entendu, bien sûr,
que nous sommes tous des soldats ici.
Donc, ce que je voudrais vraiment, vraiment vous voir faire maintenant,
c'est ramasser votre feuille de papier blanc. Est-ce tout le monde a sa feuille de papier blanc ?
Et je veux que vous sortiez un stylo,
et je veux que vous écriviez une lettre de revendication terroriste.
(Rires)
Si nous allumons le rétro-projecteur pour un moment -
Si nous allumons le rétro-projecteur, alors nous aurons, vous voyez,
Je vais vous donner un modèle à partir duquel vous pouvez travailler, ok ?
(Rires)
Maintenant je veux que vous pliiez cette lettre en forme d'avion en papier.
Et une fois pliée en forme d'avion en papier,
je veux que vous preniez de l'anthrax -
(Rires)
et je veux que vous le mettiez dans l'avion en papier.
Et puis je veux que vous le lanciez sur Jim Young.
(Rires)
J'ai eu la chance de recevoir le Prix TED cette année.
Et je voulais voir -
Je tiens à dédier ce film à mon père, Homer.
OK
Maintenant, ce film n'est pas vraiment assez difficile.
Je voulais donc le rendre un peu plus difficile.
Alors, je vais essayer de faire cela tout en récitant pi.
(Rires)
3.1415,
2657,
753,
8567,
24972 -
- 85871, 25871,
3928, 5657,
2592, 5624.
(Applaudissements)
Peut-on lancer la musique s'il vous plaît ?
Maintenant, je voulais vous parler un peu du réchauffement de la planète.
Retour en 1968,
vous pouvez voir que les montagnes de Brokeback Mountain
étaient couvertes d'un manteau neigeux de 3 mètres 83.
Entre parenthèses, là-bas sur les pentes,
je voulais vous montrer que les hommes en noir font du ski.
(Rires)
Mais au fil des ans,
10 ans plus tard, la neige s'est érodée,
et comme vous pouvez le remarquer, les arbres ont commencé à jaunir.
Le niveau d'eau du lac a commencé à baisser.
Quelques années plus tard, il n'y a plus de neige du tout.
Et tous les arbres ont viré au brun.
Cette année, malheureusement, le lit du lac
s'est transformé en un lit absolument sec et craquelé.
Et je crains, si nous ne faisons rien pour notre planète,
que dans 20 ans, il ressemble à ça.
(Rires)
Monsieur le Vice Président, j'aimerais tant savoir comment vous laisser tomber.
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup.